viele von euch haben hier in den letzten
Wochen snapchat Stories von Essentials
zugeschickt und zwar genau genommen die
Videos die unfassbare Wohnung von Luca
und so luxuriös lebt Luca in seiner
Luxuswohnung und da dort sehr häufig das
Wort Luxus
verwendet wurde dachte ich wir schauen
uns das gemeinsam mal an den Youtuber
Luca aka concrafter kennen sicher die
meisten von euch ja besser ist das ne
26-Jährige Urgestein bereitet seine
Community seit 2011 mit Videos Urgestein
wo kommt der bitschissene Begriff
eigentlich her bin ich jetzt eine Uhr
oder bin ich jetzt ein Stein angefangen
mit Minecraft fliegt sein Fokus heute
auf Unterhaltungs- ich mache immer noch
Minecraft ne
ich Stopp ein bisschen zu häufig damit
ist der auch absolut erfolgreich aber
wofür Luca auch ein wenig bekannt ist
sind seine doch ziemlich modernen
hochwertigen Wohnungen eigentlich ich
dachte für Smiley und Pizza
und natürlich meine sehr gesunde
Lebensweise ich gehe jeden Tag zum Sport
ich trink viel Wasser
eigentlich ansässig in Köln hat sich
Luca eine Wohnung in Hamburg gekauft ist
richtig eben diese geht es in unserem
heutigen Video okay
das heißt es gibt wahrscheinlich jetzt
erst um eine Hamburger Wohnung und dann
um eine Kölner und danach um die in
London Paris Los Angeles und Brüssel
wenn man durch die doch recht dicke
Eingangstür tritt sieht man direkt eine
von zwei Blickachsen hierbei hat man von
der 190 Quadratmeter großen Wohnung
neben dem Zugang zu einem der zwei
Balkone auch ein hervorragenden Blick
über Hamburg und den Fernsehturm der
Stadt der offene Eingangsbereich
eröffnet boah ich vermisse meine Haare
hier ne als erstes nehmen wir uns die
Küche vor diese ist von Luca bewusst in
schwarz gehalten ihm gefällt es wenn man
die Küche wenn es dunkel ist nicht sieht
das Besondere an dieser Küche sind neben
den versteckten Steckdosen auch die
Bedienfelder ja es gibt ganz viele
Besonderheiten die ich mir eigentlich
überlegt habe die aber glaube ich ich in
dieser roomtour von meiner Hamburger
Wohnung gar nicht richtig darstellen und
zeigen konnte weil ich weiß nicht ich
bin mit meiner extra damals das war ein
Tag bevor der Umzugs Service kam der uns
geholfen mit den ganzen zusammenpacken
da habe ich mir noch gedacht bevor jetzt
alles weg ist und ich wieder in Köln bin
ich noch mal kurz eine roomtour ich
verdiene ein riesen Fan von roomtouren
weil es ja doch ein sehr intim privater
Einblick ist und ihr wisst ja dass ich
sehr viele Informationen Familie Wohnort
Einnahmen Vermögen lieber privat halten
möchte weil ich einfach typischer alman
bin darüber ungern redet und er seine
Privatsphäre sehr gerne mag aber es gab
noch ein paar andere Kniffe in der
Wohnung die ich in diesem Video aufgrund
des Stresses gar nicht zeigen konnte
aber wenn bald die roomto von meiner
Kölner Wohnung kommt das ist auch nicht
alles fertig dann äh werde ich auf jeden
Fall mit die Zeit nehmen euch eine halbe
Stunde lang alles mal zu zeigen der
Kühlschrank das Gefrierfach und der Ofen
sind mit Hilfe von Touchfunktion
bedienbar aber nicht so beim Kochen auf
dem Herd etwas schwierig aber durchaus
machbar ja das mit dem Ofen ein bisschen
blöd weil immer wenn man gekocht hat
kann man mit dem Knie oder irgendwelchen
anderen wenn man eine kurze Hose an
hatte gegen diese komischen Touch Knöpfe
deswegen habe ich bei mir in Köln gesagt
ey ich will alles anfassen ich will
Rädchen ich will drehen ich will
Schalter ich will keinen Touch ich will
nicht über meine Handy meine Klimaanlage
steuern oder so ein Scheiß nee gib mir
einen Knopf ich drücke dir nicht ich
weiß ganz genau was passiert
sieht man aber am Herz und schaut gerade
aus sieht man auch schon das Esszimmer
ja jeder hat mich für diesen Tisch
gehatet jeder meinte immer boah ein
runder Tisch Runde Stühle alles ist
eckig und auf einmal jeder oh ja cool
haben wir alle gesagt wird super
funktionieren Idioten hier hat Luca laut
eigener Aussage das Lieblingsstück
seiner Besucher stehen ja ein ziemlich
unförmigen Tisch ohne erkennbare Kanten
ja erstmal wird kann nur mit einem n
geschrieben ne außer natürlich und nicht
alles in Ordnung aber ich bin auch
ziemlich große Kante vom Esszimmer
begeben wir uns weiter ins Wohnzimmer
hier haben wir auch die vorhin erwähnte
Aussicht über Hamburg vom Balkon hier
findet sich neben einer Fernsehecke auch
eine gemütliche U-förmige Couch von
Living divani ja damit so viele gefragt
woher die Couch ist die kann man sich so
glaube ich gar nicht mehr kaufen meine
ich weiß es aber nicht mehr genau so
oder so sind das aber alles einzelne
Teile die man sich bestellen muss und
dann einzeln zusammen stecken kann oder
auch wieder auseinander stecken kann die
Küche das Esszimmer und das Wohnzimmer
sind räumlich nicht voneinander getrennt
würde ich auch immer wieder so machen
Wohnzimmer Küche und Esszimmer muss ein
riesiger Raum sein zumindest bei mir ist
häufig so man kocht dann ist der einigen
auf dem Sofa zockt was und die anderen
sitzen schon am Tisch oder auch wenn ich
alleine bin dann gucke ich was auf dem
Fernseher während ich am Kochen bin oder
wenn ich dann im Esszimmer bin gucke ich
auch noch auf den Fernseher das muss ein
großer Raum sein am besten noch in der
Terrasse dran das hatte ich in Hamburg
das habe ich auch in Köln und auch wenn
ich jetzt demnächst irgendwann mein Haus
bauen werde wenn ich das auch machen
unten alles mit Schlafen und Bäder und
so also wenn man jetzt von zwei stoppen
spricht und dann oben Esszimmer Küche
Wohnzimmer und Terrasse alles offen
anders dagegen Lukas Büro oder das
Gästezimmer
ist es beides in einem ja was auch
beides in einem ist
[Musik]
das erste Zimmer mit Türen tatsächlich
sind das Schiebetüren eine weitere
Besonderheit der Wohnung aber dazu
gleich noch mehr okay zu dem Zimmer gibt
es nicht viel zu sagen die meisten von
euch werden diesen Raum aus seinen
Videos bereits kennen ja ich vermisse
auch so ein bisschen oh zweimal Luca mir
gerade am Start ich vermisse ehrlich
gesagt zu den persönlichen Touch der
sich irgendwie bei mir nicht mehr so
ganz wiederfindet in meinen äh Video
Hintergründen weil ich früher ja mehr
Tiefe hatte dann hatte ich hinter mir
ein riesiges Regal ich hatte teilweise
Fanpost im Hintergrund stehen Fan
Geschenke mittlerweile habe ich nur noch
diese beiden Regale hier halt seht
welchen Creeper wegen Minecraft Glurak
weil ich Pokémon Liebe hier auch wegen
Minecraft eine Potion und mein Smiley
weiß aber Logo ist viel mehr Platz habe
ich halt nicht ich habe ja noch so viele
Sachen überall stehen nicht da
hinstellen könnte soll ich mir auch
gedacht wenn ich später ein Haus baue
irgendwann und immer noch Youtube machen
sollte wenn ich mir so ein brutal geiles
Gaming Zimmer machen aber so ein cooles
so einfach winkeltes wie so ein ich weiß
ich habe so viele Ideen das wird
überhaupt das komplette Gegenteil von so
Montana black Gaming Zimmer z.B
überhaupt kein Front jeder der eigenen
Geschmack und ist ja auch gut so dass
jeder etwas unterschiedlich das gleiche
cool finden würde ich rede viel zu viel
ich liebe aber Architektur ich habe ja
Praktika in den Gebieten gemacht meine
Mom ist da tätig und so deswegen würde
ich eigentlich am liebsten auch
Architekt sein
ja ich mag das wenn Leute irgendwie über
meine Wohnung berichten oder irgendwie
sowas sagen dann dass ich meine Meinung
dazu sage also ich gehe davon auf dem
Thema deswegen okay weiter geht's ein
Unterschied zu einem normalen Youtuber
Büro ist allerdings die Schalldämmung
diese ist lackiert und passt vom Stil
auch perfekt zum Rest der Wohnung wäre
euch die Dämmung aufgefallen ja die ist
halt ziemlich versteckt ne hier auch ein
bisschen drehen
das ist alles hier alles Schalldämmung
das äh damit man halt nicht
verliert ne moin wie geht's das ist
alles damit die Zeit ne das ist halt
nicht halt und ich habe das immer
gehasst wenn Leute diese Eierschalen
Pappkartons überall hingeklebt haben und
so das ist halt eine viel schönere
Lösung mit diesem Hera Design Platten
heißen die mich auch einige gefragt ein
weiterer Unterschied gibt es noch und
zwar dieses ausklappbare Bett so schnell
ausgeklappt wird das Arbeitszimmer zum
Gästezimmer ja das ist oh
vergessen das Ding wieder zurück zu
drehen wir haben damals nach meiner
Hamburger roomtour so unfassbar viele
influencer und influencerinnen
geschrieben woher ich dir dieses
Klappbett habe aus dem Schrank was so
cool aussieht und blabla das ist alles
ja vom Tischler gemacht worden das heißt
es kann man nicht irgendwie irgendwo so
kaufen die haben da so ein Ding
entwickelt dass man so runterklappen
kann und das speziell als angepasst auf
meine Wohnung deswegen ich wünschte ich
kann euch da jetzt irgendwie was
verlinken aber ja das war halt mit dem
Tischler gemacht worden aber das ist
halt genau das was ich meine Funktion
und Ästhetik vereint so wenn ich ein
Video aufnehme ist der Hintergrund
komplett clean wenn ich kein Video
aufnehmen und Gäste sind da klappt man
den Hintergrund auf und dann kommt er
plötzlich im Bett raus weil so viel
Stauraum brauche ich nicht ich hätte
jetzt nicht Bibi mit den ganzen Einbau
Schränken aber das war so ein bisschen
der Grundgedanke nach getane Arbeit geht
es ins Bett besser gesagt ins
Schlafzimmer oder den privaten Bereich
des youtubers neben einem eigenen Bad
und selbstverständlich an dem Bett
findet sich links hinter der Tür ein
Ankleidezimmer apropos Tür
diese Tür und die Tür zum Gästebad sind
die einzigen normalen Türen in dieser
Wohnung ja weil man braucht nur Türen
zum privaten Bereich und zu den Bädern
um ein Bart abschließen zu können kann
man noch mit schiebeton und um auch den
privaten Bereich finde ich abschließen
zu können da habe ich auch hier in Köln
die einzigen richtigen Türen das würde
ich auch immer wieder so machen alles
soll offen sein
so klar wenn man jemand Kinder hat dann
klar Kinderzimmer sondern auch Türen
haben aber das war's der Rest
Schiebetüren habe ich auch hier überall
man kann die schön ineinander schieben
die verschwinden in den Wänden und so
weiter und so fort das ist voll geil der
Rest besteht aus Schiebetüren ja in
beiden Bädern finden sich Regenduschen
im Gästebad hat er sogar eine Tafel auf
der sich Freunde bei einem Besuch
eintragen können würde ich auch immer
also um einen Wohnungssuche bei dem
anderen wahrscheinlich auch ja und wenn
Leute bei mir am kacken waren die sich
ja immer die Kreide genommen dann
irgendwie forza DC welche viele Frauen
aus Bielefeld und jetzt Termine
Bielefeld oder Verein ähm so scheiße
geschrieben Pimmel dran gemacht also
habe ich irgendwann die Kreide versteckt
aber wie teuer ist Lukas Wohnung jetzt
eigentlich das ist leider nicht bekannt
ja richtig schätzungsweise liegt der
Wert der Wohnung zwischen zwei bis drei
Millionen Euro okay
das war's
von snapchat Story Nummer eins die wir
uns heute anschauen ihr wisst zu Geld
sage ich nichts deswegen werde ich auch
hier nicht zu sagen wenn man sich
Hamburger Immobilienmarkt bisschen
auskennt kann man sich den Preis
eigentlich denken
und jetzt schauen wir uns mal das andere
Video an Luca auch bekannt als
concrafter zählt zu den Youtuber
Urgestein wieder 2011 ist er auf der
Plattform präsent und seitdem gegen
seinen Weg steht bergauf daher ist es
nicht verwunderlich dass er sich auch
ein gutes Leben leisten kann wir haben
vor einiger Zeit bereits in seine
damalige Wohnungen in Hamburg
reingeschaut welche schon gut was
gemacht hat vor seiner Zeit in Hamburg
wohnte Luca jedoch in Köln wo er jetzt
doch wieder hingezogen ist ja zu damals
hat sich seine Wohnung aber schon etwas
verändert ah okay ich dachte die gehen
jetzt auf meine Kölner Wohnung ein weil
ich habe noch keinen roomto gedreht aber
wahrscheinlich nehmen Sie Ausschnitt aus
irgendwelchen Videos oder so als erstes
schauen wir uns wie gehabt den Flur an
von hier aus erreicht man problemlos
jeden anderen Raum der Wohnung das ist
der das Video von Kai Pflaume immer
nicht drauf reagiert soll ich das mal
machen schreibst du auch in die
Kommentare kein Pflaume hat mit mir
einen Tag verbracht das Video geht über
eine Stunde wenn ich da mal drauf
reagieren soll dann schreibt's mir mal
da wird meine Reaktion wahrscheinlich
auch so anderthalb Stunden gehen und
dann könnt ihr euch das mal so als Film
angucken mir ein bisschen Pizzabrötchen
rein snaken was einem direkt auffallen
dürfte es selbstverständlich der
Kontrast der Wände schwarz weiß ist eine
beliebte Kombination aber wenn wir
ehrlich sind sind die Farben das auch
aus gutem Grund mit diesem Farben lässt
sich ein kleines Raumgefühl erschaffen
ein nettes Feature befindet sich im
Gäste-WC hier hat sich Luca eine riesige
Tafel an die Wand gebaut auf der jeder
seiner Gäste unterschreiben muss eine
sehr schöne Idee das Gästebad an sich
punktet mit Lichtelementen auf der
grauen Wand in betonoptiker
[Musik]
das sind richtige Betonplatten und es
war eine Heidenarbeit über eine
Hebebühne hoch zu kriegen und überhaupt
erstmal an die ranzukommen aus
Griechenland
damit das klar ist das ist keine Optik
das sind wirkliche Betonplatten
eineinhalb nee 1 25
und diese Tafel waren da mich auch ganz
viele gefragt wo ich die her habe ist
tatsächlich eine ganz normale Wand
einfach mit tafeloptik vom Tischler vom
Maler angemalt und dann kannst du mit
mit weißer Tafelkreide einfach drauf
schreiben sein Arbeitszimmer ist etwas
ganz Besonderes ihr seht wahrscheinlich
schon was wir meinen komplett schwarz
sogar am liebsten abmachen ich habe mir
das richtig cool vorgestellt so ey der
wird die ganze Zeit an seine auch gerade
an hier und der wird dann pink leuchten
und so voll cool aber man macht die nie
an
deswegen ich bin schon kurz vor den
abzuschrauben in seinem Arbeitszimmer
gut was er da macht sagt eigentlich
schon der Name aber luca hat auch die
Möglichkeit ein Bett aus der Wand zu
zaubern ja wie in Hamburg müssen die
Gäste nicht zwingend auf die Couch in
der zockerecke geschickt werden aber
auch wohl diese auch äußerst gemütlich
aussieht so das wollte ich mir auch
gerade sagen weil voll häufig sind
Freunde hier die sich dann sagen ja die
wollen hier schlafen sich irgendwie wird
finden und gehen dann aus sofort an sich
ist das aufnahmezimmer bei mir hier eins
zu eins aus Hamburg kopiert nur ein
bisschen ja kompakter gemacht weil ich
in Hamburg zu groß fand das war mir viel
zu groß so ich liebe das auf dem kleinen
Ort zu arbeiten irgendwie ich hätte am
liebsten sondern neuen Quadratmeter
großes aufnahmezimmer gleich gerade
keine Ahnung 15 oder so aber ja wir
haben es einfach komprimiert und
komplett dunkel gemacht ich glaube sogar
wenn ich normal machen würde würde ich
entweder hier alles schwarz machen im
Hintergrund weil ich diese Ansicht dann
glaube ich sehr cool finde wenn alles so
ist wie hier so komplett schwarz aber
ich konzentriere also das ist auch so
ein bisschen in Kontrast dann damit dass
ich eigentlich Elemente von euch im
Hintergrund packen möchte oder von mir
also Smiley oder irgendwie so aber muss
ich mal schauen wie es dann demnächst
mache bei der nächsten Sache das
komplette Gegenteil zum Arbeitszimmer
ist sein Schlafzimmer dieses ist mit
hellem Holz ausgekleidet was auch einen
guten Grund hat aber dazu gleich mehr
das Bett und der Boden sind in weiß
gehalten ergänzen zum Holz und
Tageslicht kommt auch mehr als genug
hinein ein absolut beneidenswertes
Schlafzimmer aber der Grund weshalb sich
Luca für die Holzoptik im Schlafzimmer
entschieden hat ist seine eigene Sauna
ja das sollte sich einfach komplett
umziehen und wir haben generell so ein
Kubus und gedacht also das einmal das
sieht ja und die Ankleide rein komplett
aus Holz alles das sollte auch das
Schlafzimmer soll so hotelmäßig sein mit
Doppel Vorhang und so ein bisschen
Österreich mäßig dann haben wir diese
Spachtel Optik die einmal rumgeht um
Gästezimmer in Schlafzimmer rein und in
die ins Badezimmer rein ins Master
Badezimmer rein und hier ist so der
schwarze Block so das habe ich mir so
ein bisschen gedacht dass man quasi
einen großen Raum und so drei Blöcke
reinsetzt vom Ding hier dadurch zieht
sich dieser Stil eben noch durchschlafen
und Ankleidezimmer einen letzten Stopp
müssen wir aber noch einlegen
und zwar im Wohn-Esszimmer und in der
Küche diese finden wir im oberen
Stockwerk beim Betreten sehen wir auch
hier den klassischen
Schwarz-Weiß-Kontrast der Raum ist
komplett offen und hier finden wir die
Küche ja ich finde sogar die Küche sieht
noch geiler aus und generell alles sieht
geiler aus hier wenn es dunkel ist ich
habe so viele Lampen und Lichter die
alle sehr krass dimmbar sind so dass ich
ich finde es immer besser anstatt eine
große helle Leuchte zu haben ganz viele
kleine Lichtquellen die die Sonne
Atmosphäre schaffen und dann ist hier
das ganze Regal zum Beispiel leuchtet
und das kriegt man schon das sieht bei
bei Nacht das ist viel geiler aus dieses
ist mit der Couch Landschaft und dem
Boden eindeutig der hellere Bereich von
hier aus hat man auch Zugang zur
Terrasse welche sich allerdings noch im
Umbau befindet alles in allem hat Luca
sich wirklich Gedanken zu seiner Wohnung
gemacht und das merkt man auch die
Farben sind bewusst gewählt worden und
keiner geht auf die Treppe ein das ist
so unfassbar ne
einfach eine innenliegende komplette
Betontreppe auch mit dieser indirekten
Beleuchtung auch die Lampe die hier oben
ist wartet das ist so brutal diese Lampe
das sind alles handgeblasen ne nur
sexuell kleine Glaskugeln wisst ihr wie
schwer so eine kleine Glaskugel ist ich
würde sagen 20 25 kg dieses ganze Ding
mussten wir zu acht da dran machen und
jeder redet dann so darüber auch guck
mal die Stühle Neugestaltung ist zwar
schon etwas her aber sie hat sich
definitiv gelohnt
auch vorbei okay ja meine Damen und
Herren dieses Video hier wurde mir
zusammengeschnitten von den snapchat
Stories damit ich hier vernünftig drauf
reagieren kann und nicht in snapchat
damit Werbung und etc pp deswegen sieht
das hier so ein bisschen komisch aus und
auf Youtube und mit meinem Smiley unten
rechts aber das sagt Essentials zu
meinen Wohnungen wie gefallen euch meine
Wohnungen meine Einrichtungen mich
interessiert wirklich sehr weil ich
Architektur über alles feiere wisst er
deswegen wenn euch vielleicht meine
reaction drauf und einige Aussagen von
mir gefallen haben dann lasst einen
Daumen hoch unter dem Video wieder da
abonniert meinen Kanal und klickt auf
die Glocke weitere Videos nichts
verpassen ich gehe jetzt Basketball
spielen und es regnet draußen deswegen
ist es wird vielleicht auch abgesagt
aber das muss jetzt mal abklären wir
hören uns ciao